utiliza la herramienta de rotación para
determinar el ángulo de rotación
alrededor del punto 2 como -3 este es el
punto 2 menos 3 que mapear a los
segmentos h&r o en los otros segmentos
entonces aquí tenemos esta gráfica
interactiva
aquí está el segmento h y este es el
segmento de reo queremos rotar los
alrededor de este punto para que sus
imágenes después de hacer la rotación
queden mapeados en estos otros dos
segmentos ahora observando aquí parece
ser que el segmento h al hacer la
rotación se va a mapear a este segmento
y parece ser que este segmento el
segmento r o después de hacer la
rotación se va a mapear a este otro
segmento entonces juguemos un poco con
la herramienta de rotación voy a agregar
una rotación aquí y dice rotación
alrededor de ya sabemos que vamos a
rotar alrededor del punto 2 como menos 3
entonces pongo aquí 2 coma menos 3 y si
hacemos una rotación de digamos 90
grados veamos qué sucede
podemos ver que le falta que no se
llegan a mapear estos dos segmentos a
los segmentos que se nos pide ahora esto
es una rotación de un ángulo positivo 90
grados entonces como un ángulo positivo
va en el sentido contrario a las
manecillas del reloj vemos que al hacer
esa rotación el punto ere se mapea a
este punto el punto o se mate a este
punto el punto h se mapea a este punto y
el punto s mapea a este punto pero
nosotros queremos que los segmentos h&r
o se maten a estos dos segmentos no a
estos
entonces queremos que por ejemplo el
punto
semapa a este no a este así que vamos a
incrementar el ángulo de rotación en
lugar de tomar un ángulo de 90 grados
vamos a tomar uno que te parece de 135
grados veamos qué sucede
pues parece que con 135 grados casi
llegamos pero aún no estamos ahí aún le
falta entonces vamos a intentarlo con un
ángulo mayor a 135 qué te parece un
ángulo de 140 vemos que nos estamos
acercando aún más con una rotación de un
ángulo de 140 vemos que ya casi se
mapear los segmentos hr o a estos dos
segmentos casi llegamos pero todavía no
estamos ahí entonces vamos a intentarlo
con un ángulo mayor a 140 vamos a
intentarlo con un ángulo de 145 y como
puedes ver aún le falta entonces qué te
parece 150 vamos a rotar con un ángulo
de 150 ahí está
entonces parece ser que este es el
ángulo correcto 150 así que si tomamos
al conjunto de puntos que conforman los
segmentos hr o y hacemos una rotación
del punto 2 - 3 en un ángulo de 150
grados donde donde la convención es que
el giro de este ángulo es en el sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj
entonces estos dos segmentos se apearán
a estos dos segmentos es decir sus
imágenes después de la rotación
alrededor de este punto se matarán a
estos dos segmentos y vemos que el punto
o se mate a este punto el punto ere se
mapea a este punto el punto ese mapa a
este y el punto h a este y por ejemplo
si tomamos este punto que está a la
mitad del segmento h
al hacer la rotación se va a mapear a
este punto que está justo a la mitad de
este segmento